good morning afternoon or evening to
this distributed audience I'm glad to
have a chance to talk to you about the
human connectome project let me start
with some numbers I love numbers about
the brain each of you turned into this
has a brain with about 86 billion
neurons in the several pounds of our
squishy tissue fitting inside your skull
the dominant structure that you see on
the left is the cerebral cortex it
contains about eighty percent of the
brain mass but it's really only twenty
percent of the total neuronal count
that's because it's dominated by the 150
trillion or so synapses that communicate
information from one neuron to another
and it also involves about a hundred
thousand miles worth of white matter
axons conveying information over long
distances the cerebellum is a tiny
structure on the lower left that's about
ten percent of the brain mass it
actually contains the great majority of
all your neurons and then there's
another collection of structures the
rest of the brain that are basically
subcortical nuclei that are critically
important for keeping us alive and well
even though there are very few in number
fewer than 1% of your total neuronal
count so our challenge for today and for
the rest of the century if not the
millennium is to do our best to untangle
this extremely complicated network of
connections that makes us alive well and
incredibly able to do complex
intellectual things such as generate and
just listen to this presentation
analogies are often made between brains
and computers even though physically
they're very different the computer
power has continued to escalate it was
15 years ago or so that the World
Championship in chess was handed over to
a computer computers do their business
by processing elements hardware that can
literally do gigaflops worth
tations yet our brains do amazingly well
with neurons and synapses that operate
at a much slower speed impulses on the
order of one to a hundred spikes per
second so the challenge for computers is
to understand the operation of the
system at the level of the hardware the
operating systems and the many
applications that make our computers
useful for the brains that we're dealing
with today we want to understand the
wiring the signals that physiologically
carry information from one place to
another we want to use it to understand
our own behaviors that well as out of
animal models over the past decade
there's been much excitement about the
general domain of conecto makes a
connectome is in quotes a comprehensive
map of neuronal connections but we put
it in quotes because it's comprehensive
only to a particular scale so i'll be
talking today about the macroscopic
scale what we call the macro connectome
exploration of long-distance connections
from one catch a grey matter to another
through the underlying white matter but
down to the resolution of the imaging
elements the voxels that are on the
order of one to two millimeters on a
side there's another world of the micro
connectome that aims to reconstruct in
exquisite detail every neuron glial cell
axon dendrite and synapse but currently
that's achievable attainable only to the
level of a refraction of the cubic
millimeter that is lesson one of the
voxels of the image the human brain
would intermediate in this realm is the
world of the mezzo connectome which uses
an anatomical tracers in animal models
to explore local and long distance or
connections with intermediate spatial
resolution so as I said earlier we're
going to focus on the macro connect them
in the human brain before we get to the
human connectome project proper I want
to give some important introductory
overview
it's about cerebral cortex in general
and enamels about cartography
connectivity and individual variability
peoples are really critical to
understanding the scope of the problem
and the ways in which we can affect it
so brains come in many sizes our brain
is about a thousandfold larger than the
mouse brain and has more than a thousand
times as many neurons macaque monkey
monkey which is the most intensively
studied animal model is ten times
smaller than our brains and our brains
are three times larger than that of a
chimpanzee shown on the left that's our
closest living or grade 8 relative you
can see at a glance at the cortical
convolution vary enormously from the
smooth brain listen cephalic mouth to
our highly convoluted cortex and that
brings us to the realm of cortical conic
cartography I am a card-carrying
cartographer of the brain I've been
doing it for several decades I started
several back in the 1970s literally
using pencil and tracing paper to make
flat maps as you can see in the lower
left of this panel of the macaque monkey
cerebral cortex the fortunes involved
envision a decade or so later my
colleague Dan koloman and I were able to
make a manually pencil and tracer map of
the entire macaque cerebral cortex and
to use information from the literature
to parcel eight the cortex into dozens
of distinct cortical areas that the
colored runs are visual areas in macaque
monkey identified on the basis of
differences or distinctiveness in their
function their architecture their
connectivity and or their topography
that is the representations of the
visual world mapped onto the cortical
sea and a couple of those areas of the
primary visual area v1 as well as the
little tiny area MT our poster children
in the sense that they were identifiable
by all of these methods and were
consistently and reliably studied most
other cortical areas at that time and
even to this day
have fuzzy boundaries and it's are still
contentious after exactly where the
boundaries are for many of these it's
just hard to make accurate maps of
animal models and even harder when we
get to the human cerebral cortex as
you'll see but we are making headway
part of the challenge in dealing with
the human cortex is the vastly greater
complexity of the convolutions on the
left you see a structural magnetic
resonance imaging or MRI slice and that
is the one slice cut about midway
through the brain cerebral cortex is on
the top the cerebellum is on the bottom
and the cerebral partridges cortex is
outlined by little gray green and blue
contours that capture the shape of the
coralville compilations in every single
slice we can use that information to
generate three-dimensional models such
as the type you see on the right or the
three-dimensionality captures all the
intricacies of the cortical folds we can
use that to nap information we can also
inflate and visualize inside the pearls
as you'll see in later slides I
mentioned the challenges of parcel ation
now let's have an update of where we are
in this decade the mouse as I said
there's a much simpler model and it's
also been mapped more accurately from
the there are about 40 different
cortical areas that andreas birth alters
lab has charted some large some small
but they were hiding the entire surface
and they've been mapped with
considerable fidelity the macaque monkey
which we look at next here is an
inflated version of the macaque mapping
and an updated parcel ation scheme which
shows about a 130 cortical areas so it's
more extensive than the previous map but
it's not ground truth or as I said
before are still debates about many of
these boundaries so the human cortex
shown on the right
we have accurate maps to currently of
about 50 different areas shown in colors
on this on the surface model that's been
inflated and those are accurately mapped
using anatomical as well as functional
MRI methods but there are large gaps in
between where we know a lot but we don't
have accurate cartographic maps we
estimate that by the time these gaps are
filled in in the next year or so using
data from the human connectome project
there may be a hundred and fifty to two
hundred areas are but doing an accurate
mapping of that is a major challenge one
way we can get a handle on this is to
compare across species I mentioned
earlier that the macaque is one-tenth
the size of our brain but the
differences are that have occurred
during recent human evolution are
dramatic in terms of their regional
specificity so these figures show the
degree of expansion during the recent
human evolution and the red hot spots
that are you can see in the middle panel
show regions of 20 to 30 fold expansion
in human cortex relative to the mechanic
and these regions are turn out to be our
domains that are implicated in higher
cognitive functions in humans we can
also compare across species using maps
of Milan content so in this lower panel
the red and yellow regions are regions
that are heavy and Milan content they
communicate information faster and in
the human cortex what you can see is it
in the blue regions here they are more
likely myelinated and that is restricted
to the domains that have expanded most
recently and are involved in higher
cognitive function so this basic
anatomical feature of Milan content is a
signature of functional organization and
we can also compare the Milan maps
across species
chimpanzees it's hard to get a lot of
data from chimpanzees but one that is
peace feasible is to get these my land
maps that you can see here and you can
see as the arrow show that the regions
of chimpanzee cortex that are blue and
presumably implicated in higher
cognitive function are much smaller than
any human so that the explosion of human
cortical tissue is devoted primarily to
the things that make us smarter with
make it makes sense but it's nice to
have anatomical evidence for this so a
few basics about connectivity again
giving you a quick historical
perspective decades ago we thought the
connections between the brain in the in
the monkey two different visual areas we
had only a handful that could be
identified on 15 years later my graduate
student John Mansell identified more
pathways but also showed that the
different cortical areas can be arranged
in a hierarchy from lower visual
processing in v1 and v2 up to many
higher stages and Dan Fellman and I
carried this even farther with this
subway chart kind of visualization
domain that you see in the lower left
that contains dozens of visual areas and
several hundred connections and we could
also display the same information as a
connectivity matrix a 32 by 32 array
showing the presence or absence of
connections between different visual
areas it was frustrating at the time
that there was very little quantitative
data available even though we knew that
there was a wide range of connection
strengths a decade later my graduate
student Jim Lewis made maps of cortical
connectivity for selected tracer
injections into different visual areas
showing that it was possible to quantify
this but it was extremely hard work and
we only had a handful of such charts at
that time a decade later in the past
several years Henry Kennedy's lab have
carried this a major ways forward in a
way that gives us a quantitative map of
action strengths for dozens of cortical
areas such as the arrow pointing to an
injection in the lower left here of
visual area B 2 and the connectivity
that you can see in the panel in the
upper right shows a handful of
connections that are very strong
powerful and many that are intermediate
in the middle range and many that are
very weak and this is a logarithmic plot
so the range of connection strengths
revealed by this are literally five
orders of magnitude and when this is
done on 29 different injected areas one
gets a map shown on the right here of
over 1,600 pathways identified to date
and extrapolation would suggest there
are five thousand or more pathways in
the macaque monkey and presumably the
same in the human so we should
appreciate that when we want to explore
the human connectome we should expect to
find an extraordinarily complex set of
connectivity patterns adding to the
challenge is not only the degree of
complexity of human cortical
convolutions but also their variability
from one individual to the neck so each
of you has a unique pattern of cortical
folding the for example shown here if
you look closely you can see they there
are some similarities but a lot of
differences and that's true even though
these are for individuals were chosen
from a set of identical twins so to
these identical twins and it would be
very hard for you to look at this and
identify based on the folding
characteristics who are the twins so
I'll just show you the answer the upper
pair are identical twins and yet look at
the arrows the folding patterns are
strikingly different in many regions
despite their genetic identity saying
for the lower ones and so what this
shows us one has looked at
quantitatively and carefully is that
there is some heritability to cortical
folding patterns but it's much less than
you might have guessed and that brings
me to an important sidebar comment about
the nature of cortical
folding and why does the cortex actually
fold and I'll give you my perspective on
this which was a lightbulb moment that
came on about 17 years ago it started
with the realization that cortical
folding occurs in humans in late
gestation the third trimester of
gestation and it occurs right around the
time that long-distance pathways are
being established within the underlying
white matter I wondered whether that was
a coincidence or whether there was a
cause-and-effect relationship and I was
aware of experimental studies that axons
at least in a tissue culture dish
actually generate a little bit of
mechanical tension and so that led to
the idea schema ties in the right-hand
panel here that long distance
connections through the newly
established white matter could lead to
cortical folding if all of the axons
between one cortical area and another
gently pulled together bringing the
tissue closer and forming a gyro sensor
folding in some regions such as the
central sulcus and the calcarine sulcus
and the variability in regions that are
above a nice set of competing areas that
may differ in size and connectivity
patterns so this is an attractive
hypothesis it helps us think rationally
about the nature of cortical folding but
I have to be honest and say this is
unproven hypothesis it's difficult to
get our compelling evidence that I think
it's a remains highly plausible and
attractive whatever the mechanism the
practical reality for those of us
interest in exploring the human brain
and the cerebral cortex we have to bring
data together into a common spatial
framework what we call a brain atlas if
we want to carefully and quantitatively
compare across subjects in the past this
has traditionally been done as shown on
the left-hand panels by aligning the
structural MRI volumes for many
individuals onto a target population
average atlas that works especially well
for these subcortical structures the
basal ganglia of the thalamus and the
like because of their relative
consistency but it doesn't work terribly
well for the cerebral cortex because of
the complexity and variability of the
convolutions that we've already
discussed so instead the field is
advanced by converting to surface-based
registration to align across individual
three both hemispheres and the example
shown here is one that we published a
decade ago which uses a selected set of
consistently locally localized landmarks
to register individuals through an atlas
but that's now a historical relic
because we and many others have reverted
or converted to an improved intersubject
registration approach developed by bruce
official and used with the free server
software which does a better job of
aligning based on shape characteristics
across individuals and you can see a
population average particles sheet on
the right there and it's better than its
predecessors but it's not perfect and
the way to justify that assertion is to
note that some cortical areas such as
the little red patch of architectonic
lee defined area v1 is in fact
accurately and consistently registered
across many individuals whereas on the
lower right there a nearby visual area
the so-called mt + of complex is not
accurately aligned using folding
characteristics alone and that's because
the variability of the folds and the
variability in the location of
identified areas in relation to these
folds up prevents folding based
alignment from doing a great job on its
own and I'll return to that because I'll
show you a little bit later examples of
how we can actually improve the
alignment across subjects in ways that
are critical for getting a better handle
on human cortical organization so that
brings me at long last to the human
connectome project I'll give you a quick
overview and then take you through
illustrations of where we are in a
wiring and analyzing a different
modalities of information that inform
the connectome project first I should
applaud the contributions of over 100
investigators and staff members who have
been working for the past four years to
get this project underway and it's
centered at Washington University and
University of Minnesota with Mike OPI
Camille Hooverville in Minnesota but it
involves ten different institutions
around the world so our objectives in
the human connectome project are to
study 1,200 healthy adults not drawn
randomly from the streets of st. Louis
but rather selected from a population of
twins and their non Quinn siblings so
we're targeting 150 identical twins 150
fraternal or dizygotic twins and were
more than halfway through that
acquisition effort is all come to in a
moment but we spent the first two years
of the project improving both the
hardware and the data acquisition and
analysis methods the scanner we are
using is a customized Siemens sciver a
33 Tesla scanner that has a stronger
gradient insert 100 Militello per meter
that lets us get better diffusion
imaging data we're also just about to
start scanning up at minnesota 200 of
these 1,200 subjects using a seven Tesla
scanner that will improve that data
quality for several modalities a major
advance involved the utilization of
advanced pulse sequences in particular
what's called multiband parallel imaging
that I'll illustrate in a moment that
gives us much better data quality and
we're applying that to get diffusion
imaging that informs our analysis of
long-distance pathways through
tractography and also resting-state
functional connectivity and task fMRI as
I'll illustrated in a few moments we are
currently acquiring information from a
different modality as well and magneto
encephalopathy acquired it our
our institution st. Louis University and
we're targeting 100 subjects over the
coming year for each of our participants
we get several hours worth of behavioral
data that allows us as we move forward
in the analysis to compare connectivity
and brain function with specific
behavioral phenotypes are drawn from the
information in this behavioral
repertoire we are acquiring our blood
samples as well and we will be
genotyping next year to provide
information along that other dimension
we're already making these data freely
available and are not in adjusted cordon
repository rather a user-friendly
informatics platform that will touch
upon later so we want this to be a
resource for discovery science and a
baseline for future studies of brain
diseases and disorders as I mentioned we
spent a major amount of time actually
two years at the start of the project
for the refinement and optimization
effort not only the improved pulse
sequences that I've mentioned already
but also better analysis methods and
improved visualization and informatics
platforms and if you're interested in
the details on any of these fronts there
are eight papers that came out last year
in a special issue on the connect them
in the journal neural image now we're in
the middle of Phase two we have a year
and a half left to acquire the 1,200
subject and we're on pace to do that
last fall we release data extensive data
set from over 200 subjects and later
this spring we're going to release the
data for 500 subjects there was also a
recent release of the initial
acquisition of em eg data and we're
continuing to improve our data mining
capabilities let me just touch briefly
on emmy gee i won't have time to say too
much about it but the attractiveness of
it is that it's the one modality that
gives us high spatial resolution as you
can see here it has a smaller number of
sensors
on 248 for the device that we're using
it gives millisecond time resolution but
much coarser spatial resolution than the
than the functional MRI but the two
together on the same subjects are going
to add to the overall capabilities for
deep level analysis and just to
illustrate that this can work using
other data sets our colleagues in chieti
and Washington University have shown
that Emmy g is able to identify resting
state networks shown in the different
colors there that are closely matched to
the functional MRI based resting state
networks that have been identified in
other studies and so we're requiring
resting state mhe as well as task emmy
gee and we'll be continuing to release
on these data sets as they're requiring
the main modalities relate to MRI as
i've indicated before and the multiband
image acquisition is stina ties on the
right there normal fMRI has
traditionally acquired data one slice at
a time from the bottom of the top or top
of the bottom of the brain multiband
imaging allows us to apply ER excite up
to eight slices at a time has shown in
this illustration and even more is
possible in some pool sequences and then
the the image data are acquired using a
multi-channel head coil that is
sensitive in a spatially distributed way
and intensive reconstruction
sophisticated algorithms can be used on
alias the data and extract the spatial
localization very accurately so already
more than a hundred sites around the
world are using this multiband approach
to get better temporal resolution as
well as facial resolution I'll
illustrate this in the context of
diffusion imaging first the white matter
is known from classical blunt dissection
methods to involve cables running over
long distances and
spaghetti like configurations here
illustrate that there is a lot of
coherence or cold axial alignment of
white matter axons even though each
little bundle each square millimeter of
cross-sectional area has literally
hundreds of thousands of axonal fibers
mostly myelinated running through it
it's also known from the classical
literature that there's a lot of
tangling a lot of crossing fibers that
are needed to carry information in the
many different directions and if you'll
recall what I took pains to point out
about macaque cortical connectivity if
there are literally many many thousands
of long-distance connections then the
wiring that mediates them must surely be
very complex diffusion imaging is an
attractive method for deciphering many
aspects of long-distance connectivity it
relies on the fact that diffusion of
water a long axons goes faster than it
does when water tries to diffuse across
at our own axonal membranes and
myelinated wrappings around these axons
and the pole sequences that we use
involve high angular resolution hundreds
of different orientations are probed for
each voxel in throughout the brain and
then the data can be analyzed in order
to estimate not only the dominant fiber
bundle orientation but up to two or
three alternative or crossing fiber
orientations in each voxel and so the
this has been around for many years now
the the advantage is provided by the
connectome project are that we're using
a scanner with stronger gradient
strength we're using multiband in this
case of multiband factor three that
allows us to get diffusion imaging voxel
sizes of a millimeter and a quarter
which is notably good relative to what's
common in the field up to now we also
have improved algorithms for better
orientation estimation in
each voxel and improvements are
generated by the Oxford diffusion
imaging group to use probabilistic
tractography to estimate the likelihood
of long-distance connections inferred
from the diffusion imaging data a proof
of this is shown in the slide you see
now on the left is the results of
probabilistic tractography from a seed
location place in the primary motor
cortex and using conventional 2
millimeter diffusion imaging acquisition
on the far right is the same seed
location but now applied to a subject
scanned in our connect on scanner with a
higher resolution and better data
quality and what you can see in this
axial slice is on the connectome project
data we can accurately identify four
different long-distance tracks from
motor cortex to various subcortical our
targets whereas the data is coarser and
has many more false positives using
conventional diffusion imaging data our
weekend if I can get the oh I now
remember that I need to go to the next
set of slides or hang on for a second
now we can look not just one slice at a
time but we construct and estimate
long-distance connections so we can take
for this individual subject and take a
seed location at the blue spot in the
inferior frontal gyrus and take a
coronal slice through that part of the
brain and then exhume it up our so we
can look more closely at it this next
slide shows you the estimate of fiber
orientation in all voxels in this slice
then the probabilistic tractography
approach takes a seed location at the
tip of the inferior frontal gyrus where
the little arrow says seed and shows the
probabilistic estimate of long distance
connections going through that
particular
slides but of course the actual
connections go through a complex
three-dimensional trajectory and our
connectome workbench visualization
platform allows one to see of not only
selected brain slices but the 3d
trajectory shown in different colors to
indicate the dominant direction in which
the fiber bundles are passing through
each our location this is a 3d image and
the weave I am NOT able to show you a
movie here but the workbench platform
allows you to animate this so you can
see the three dimensionality through
whatever degree you like we can
visualize and analyze not only the
connections within the white matter but
we can assess their terminations from
one gray matter region to another and we
can map the estimated connection density
as shown in these lower panels by the
seed location again are in the frontal
cortex this is in the approximately the
middle frontal sulcus and and the red
region so local are strong connectivity
in this subject as well as long distance
connections to the parietal and temporal
cortex and that can be also seen on the
lower right on an inflated surface where
the analysis has been carried out an
average across nine of our connect on
subjects so it's encouraging that we can
see these long-distance connections
there are also some important technical
challenges and limitations if you look
closely many of the moderate connection
strengths on the lower left panel there
seemed to run along gyro riches and that
is in fact consistently the case and we
it's a problem to deal with that we at
least understand the nature of the
problem even as we're working to find
better ways to cope with it so if you
look at the ski motivations and brain
slice is shown here we can take in panel
B an exemplar
gyro ridge a gyro crown and the white
matter blade that runs under inside that
gyro ridge and schematically we would
hope that the axon feeding into this
part of cortex are running coherently
and peeling off in an orderly way to
carry information to and from the
soulful banks as well as a gyro crown at
the top but diffusion imaging because of
its poor for spatial resolution is
dominated by the signals of the fiber
orientations going up to the crown of
the ridge and as a consequence it is
inherently the case that as shown on the
panels on the right for the human cortex
and the monkey cortex that the density
of tractography streamlines is much
greater on gyro crowns than it is on
circle banks or the depths of society
that's what the cartography suggests but
it's not an atomic or reality and I
harken back to the slide of the type I
showed you previously from retrograde
tracers in macaque monkeys that give us
a closer estimate of anatomical ground
truth the red dot showed that an
injection site in temporal cortex are
deals strong labeling ins gyro sokol
banks and sopel fund i as well as in
tyrell crowns and so it's unlikely that
the bias suggested by if using imaging
reflects anatomical reality it's more a
methodological limitation so we can hope
in the future that it will be possible
to get better data that reduce that bias
it may be possible to use anatomical
priors to more accurately model the
actual distribution of connections but I
would stress that in reading and working
with diffusion imaging data it's very
important not to over interpret the data
and to be aware of the technical
compounds so that's a quick glimpse of
diffusion imaging let me move on to
functional MRI and give you an
our of what we can learn from cast fmri
so in the connectome project we have
seven different tasks three of which
I'll illustrate briefly one of them is a
language task each participant listens
to stories in the scanner and then
alternates that with doing arithmetic
problems there's another task that
involves social cognition these are in
the scanner their animations and the
social paradigm the triangle are kissing
and hugging one and dancing with one
another in the random movement they're
just randomly drifting around the
working memory task are our challenges
each participant to remember whether
their current image on the screen
matches one to previously and if we look
at the kinds of results we can get from
this kind of task this next slide shows
you the anatomical substrate that
connect on workbench offers for
visualization of all parts of interest
in the cortical gray matter so we see
the anatomical inflated surface of the
left and right Schriever for hemispheres
from lateral and medial views and the
that slices on the upper right show the
subcortical gray matter and we can also
visualize the data on this flat map of
the cerebellar cortex so if we are
showing the group average results for
the connectome task fMRI task involving
listening to stories verses are hearing
math arithmetic problems you can see
there's a very complex pattern of
activation in yellow and red and
deactivation in blue and green that
involves many different locations in
particularly in the temporal lobe and
also in the cerebellum in the same set
of participants if we look at the social
interactions task we see a another
complex pattern that shows some overlap
but many distinctive regions compared to
the previous one and if we look at the
working memory we see a very different
or but still distributed pattern of
spatial activate
so to cut to the chase what we're
learning from this is that each task
engages a complex network of brain
regions that are partially overlapping
with those involved in other tasks to
further decipher this we're using the
method or resting-state functional
connectivity that has received a lot of
attention in recent years of the
advantages we have for the connectome
project or the higher quality better
spatial resolution the better temporal
resolution each brain volume so far TR
is acquired in seven tenths of a second
instead of multiple seconds and the
patterns we see at one instance are in
this schema disease or this illustration
on the left if we had a dynamic movie
that I could tell you you'd see these
fluctuations of high and low Bloods bold
fmri signal show a complex exquisite
orchestration of fluctuations that are
so many correlations so if we take the
time course for two different regions we
may see that they're strongly correlated
or that they're anti-correlated or
uncorrelated and if we do that for all
possible combinations of gray matter
locations surface vertices and
subcortical voxels of grey matter we
have end up with a 90,000 by 90,000
connectivity matrix what we call a
functional dense connect on that's about
30 gigabytes of data for each subject
and we can interrogate that at the level
of individual subjects or a group
averages and use is to examine
functional connectivity maps for example
location one is a seed location in the
parietal cortex or the right hemisphere
and it shows strong functional
connectivity both locally and at a long
distance in the opposite hemisphere and
up in the frontal loads a different seed
location such as that in somatic sensory
cortex there is a totally different
pattern of functional connectivity we
can produce in great detail but when we
want to compare across individuals we
have to revisit this issue of the
complexity of cortical folding and how
it varies across subjects and I want to
illustrate the importance of this and
how we're making headway in getting
better intersubject alignment using the
multimodal surface matching method
developed by our colleague Emma Robinson
and mark Jenkins in at Oxford University
to remind you that the problem that we
face this is a expanded view of what I
show the earlier standard foaming based
registration on the cortical surface
align some regions like being one very
well but does poorly at other regions
like the MP complex the multimodal
surface matching method is a
sophisticated project process I won't
try to explain the details i'll just
show you a demonstration of how it can
in fact work starting with an example
from individual subjects and group
averages using our older method so on
the upper left you see the cortical
folding pattern for one individual
subject the second panel shows the
individual subjects Milan map with the
somatic motor strip the red strip in the
middle and various other hot spots
including those shown by the green and
blue arrows if we probe that individual
subjects functional connectivity by
putting a seed at the location of the
green arrow and parietal cortex we see
hot spots of Khan functional
connectivity such as a frontal eye field
shown in the third panel on our Army's
top row and that corresponds to a gap in
the task activation of the math purchase
story contrast if we do the same thing
on another subject we have a different
folding pattern a different individual
subjects Milan map of where we can see
similar cabins but they're not precisely
vocalized and that's true for the
functional connectivity and the past
activation so when we use conventional
our group averaging and alignment we get
in the lower or row the middle the
second panel shows you the there is
reasonably good but still somewhat fuzzy
alignment of the Milan maps the hotspots
in
the green and blue arrows are bit fuzzy
and so is the functional connectivity
and the task activation whereas if we do
the same analysis but now using the
functional connectivity and a mile and
maps to improve the registration it's
dramatically better in particularly in
the region shown in the lower panel so
now the group average Milan is much
sharper as is the group average
functional connectivity and the task
activation if I go back to the previous
panel is fuzzy if I go back to the MSM
based multimodal registration it's
sharper in the group average and that's
because the spatial pattern shown in the
upper panels have gotten our line using
the functional and Milan map data so
that's the proof of concept has its
excited about the way we can advance the
analysis of cortical organization and
function now I want to give you in the
last few minutes a few illustrations of
how we can use this kind of data to
explore interesting aspects of brain
function in its relationship to behavior
so one approach pioneered by Steve Smith
at Oxford and his colleagues uses
independent components analysis or I see
a decomposition who identify spatially
localized regions are based on the
commonality of their functional MRI time
series data so here are exemplars I see
a nodes showing in the upper panel the
anode involved in the somatosensory and
motor face representation region the
second panel shows you a node thats
related to the hand representation just
in the left hemisphere the lower two
panels show you two different nose
relating to central vision and
peripheral vision concentrated in
McAlpin Soltis area v1 one can do that
for the in this example on 98 different
ica components and in the upper left of
modern is a functional correlation
matrix connectivity matrix using the
full correlation that is that the time
series data after cleaning up with
denoising techniques and you can see a
rich and complex pattern of connectivity
that can be sorted according to major
brain networks that are shown on the
upper right so these ten different brain
networks are identified based on the
commonality of their functional MRI data
it's similar to what's been published in
other studies by Randy butters lab and
see Peterson's lab but here we're
getting a finer spatial granularity
thanks to the higher quality of the data
we can also regress out the common
features and generate a partial
correlation network such as that shown
in the lower right below the diagonal
and that gives us what may be a better
estimate of a selective connectivity
between each of these ICA are nodes or
parcels so this can be done not only in
the group average is some here but in
individual subject so we can take the
group average partial correlation matrix
that's now reoriented and occupies the
upper right hand and we can use use the
dual regression approach developed by
Steve Smith and colleagues to identify
the partial correlation matrix for each
individual subject and we can reorganize
this data set into essentially a long
4700 on values for each of our pair of
network edges and we can do that for all
131 subjects for this analysis and the
streakiness indicates the commonalities
of functional connectivity patterns
across individuals and now we can take
this rich data collection and correlate
it with behavioral measures and the same
population of subjects as well as to
analyze heritability
just to give you teasers to illustrate
the proof of concept if we use the
observed intelligence value by the major
of behavioral intelligence the fluid
intelligence that we have we can compare
that to the predicted intelligence
measure using the functional
connectivity data and they are in fact
correlated and we can use that to
identify which pairs of conic
connections or which edges in the
connectivity matrix are most informative
and the most informative particular one
is a connection between the frontal lobe
and the medial hippocampal region has
shown here another one that is of
interest is a connection between the
cerebellum and the parietal and temporal
independent components node so this is
just a teaser one other example shown in
the next slide if we take the functional
connectivity data and compare the the
entire functional connectivity matrix
for individual all individual pairs but
group them according to whether they are
monozygotic twins as shown in the upper
left for dizygotic twins as shown in the
second column you can see that the
functional connectivity maps are more
strongly to correlate 'add for
monozygotic comparative dizygotic twins
and that in fact is evidence that there
is the strong heritability of the
functional connectivity it's not
surprising but what's nice about this
analysis is that we can now program more
closely and identify which connections
are contributing most strongly to this
heritability estimate on good
connections is between the language
cortex a green apps shown in the upper
panels and the so called default mode
network it's of interest to many
investigated again this is just the tip
of the iceberg
things that we've been starting to
afford it in the consortium but everyone
can join in this kind of effort because
we're already sharing the data the Human
Genome Project demonstrated the
importance and value of widespread data
sharing if you go to our connect on BB
database once you sign the data use
terms you can get access to the data
sets by downloading it or by ordering
connect them in a box if you want all of
it to the data sets we've already
released data from 216 subjects and it's
not just the unprocessed data but we're
providing or for every subject the
minimally pre-process data using the
methods we developed and refined in the
connectome project and we're also
providing extensively for the process
data as that becomes available using the
methods were intimately work on the
imaging data and most of the behavioral
data are open access it's very simple to
get signed those data whose terms if you
want anything to do with family
structure or other sensitive data you
need to agree to our restricted date of
these terms but that is a very
manageable thing that many people were
doing so altogether to wrap this up
understanding the human brain and
healthy disease is a brand talent for
our century if not millennium the
connectome project is contributing to
this by giving us insights about brain
connectivity and how it varies and
healthy adults were already starting to
see major discoveries and insights but
we should be mindful that a complete
connectome across all spatial scales is
well outside our grasp owing the
methodological arm limitations so we
need to be optimistic but have a
critical eye towards methodological
limitations and challenges for each of
these methods but we do hope and expect
that we'll learn from this insights that
are relevant to future studies or
diseases development and aging again I
thank the many different members who've
worked intensely over many years
particularly my colleague Camille
verville in Minnesota and my talented
graduate student in that blaster he
developed many of the methods and
pipelines that you saw here and we first
appreciate our funding from the NIF link
print and to close it out I'll just make
another analogy to the cartography or
conical perspective that I mentioned at
the beginning he's seen revolutions in
earth map from the earliest classical
maps and likewise through the brain
gurgaon gave us a wonderful classical
map we moved to a stage of book atlases
of the earth and the brain then new
imaging methods gave with satellite
images of the earth and functional in
structural MRI views of the brain Google
Earth has truly transformed the way we
live and navigate across the earth at
many scales and we hope that the domain
of comic comics will continue to expand
its horizons in terms of better methods
of analyzing human brain circuits and
function and relation to behavior and
health and disease so thank you for your
attention and I'll leave it on that and
I will be happy to answer any questions
so the are just read of the questions as
they come does a study of consciousness
feature anywhere of the tools of the
project I would say yes and no the
information that we have in the resting
state and the task fMRI data is a very
rich domain for exploration and the
dynamics of brain circuits can be
explored we're using these data sets and
the community I think clever
investigators will be able to take these
data and explore different issues
potentially even informing us about
aspects of consciousness and changes in
certainly changes in mental state are
associated with the rich information
that we have from the second question is
can you track down different dopamine
circuits through the brain and body
that can be done using other imaging
methods such as positron emission
tomography pet is increasingly used in
for studies of Parkinson's disease for
example but it's not part of the data
acquisition protocol for the connectome
project we hope as I touched upon before
that the insights about healthy brain
circuits and organization will provide a
better baseline where r with which
studies of dopamine circuits and other
many other kinds of clinically relevant
questions will be informed by an
improved study of how the healthy brain
is organized and Riley the third
question is the human connect on project
able to validate the lateralization
theory or the top to bottom brain theory
I can't speak to those in detail but
again I would emphasize that by making
these data available to the community
it's up to the cleverness and energy of
the community broadly to see whether
this on uniquely rich and extensive set
of data can inform a variety of
different models of brain function and
organization the question number four is
are the areas correlated with
intelligence the same as those that
differ between humans and chimps the
short answer is we're really still
scratching the surface of that and the
preliminary data that i feel you was
based on still a modest number of twins
so i expect we will get a much more
detailed and refined assessment as we
get additional data acquired released
and analyzed i would be intrigued by
that possibility but i would not say
that our evidence strongly supports or
contradicts that hypothesis at this
stage but it's definitely one of the
kinds of questions we would like to see
addressed
we're next question is a correlation or
insight seen for autism or other
different conditions we hope so in the
long run because we're studying healthy
adults we certainly don't have direct
evidence pertaining to specific diseases
but the ability to explore our brain
circuits vary with behavioral phenotype
some of which are characteristics that
are studied in autism may allow
exploration of this I will also mention
that we are also at the beginning of a
pilot phase of acquiring data at
different age ranges are part of a
lifespan pilot project that the NIH
granted a supplement for and we hope to
learn more about changes in brain
circuits across age ranges from 406 the
youngest age up to 65 to 75 of the
oldest ages that will give us a window
on developmental and aging related
changes but studies of specific diseases
will definitely require other projects
that we hope will be inspired by the
methodological advances that net from
project is provided the next question is
what do you think is the greatest
challenge in matching functional MRI
data with higher resolution functional
having to expand this would we find
functional microscopy data such as
optimal off of genetic experiments and
small primates that's another very
interesting challenge one of the things
it is not part of the connectome project
per se but my lab is certainly
interested and is making more accurate
comparisons of across species using what
we call interspecies registration of the
cortical surface and that will provide
us better comparisons of what are likely
the homologous read the first species
but the challenges that relate to
looking at different spatial scales such
as what optogenetics provide there are
host of challenges but I'm excited by
the prospects of improved methods
invoked by the brain initiative that I
think will be discussed in a following
presentation this morning and it's a
wide world for exploration next question
can you recognize listening patterns in
a patient apparently unconscious or coma
patients again this is outside the scope
of the connectome project but there is a
lot of effort using functional MRI to
explore brain circuits in a variety of
conditions including unconscious at coma
patients so there is an emerging
literature on that i'm not expert in it
but it is a well worth exploration and
will hopefully will we will see better
data emerging from explorations that use
the improve data acquisition and
analysis methods that I can't
illustrated here so that is the end of
the questions I see on the list and it's
also the end of the hour so I will take
this to the next stage thank you for
your attention and encourage those of
you who are interested in seeing the
credit to follow this next step so thank
you for your attention